sincèrement legolas il m'a traumatisé je
pète un câble sur legolas je voulais me
laisser pousser les cheveux c'était
n'importe quoi
[Musique]
j'ai hâte que le film commence c'est
assez particulier quand même comme
expérience de se retrouver avec des
inconnus pendant deux heures de savoir
qu'on voit rien n'est changé
physiquement ou verbalement qui
comparent sentir plus ou moins les mêmes
émotions au même moment pendant 1h30
1h50 c'est une expérience assez
fascinante à la belle et la bête c'était
avec l'école j'étais en cm1 ou cm2 je
crois une sortie organisée par le par
l'école et je me rappelle pas ce que je
souhaite à la grande époque disney on a
eu de la chance il y avait la belle et
la bête après ya eu à la d'un le roi
lion à la suite comme ça c'était fou et
je voulais pécho une oeuvre qui était
dans ma classe je m'identifie à la bfc
tu vois on peut être poilu est sympa
quand tu vois c'est pas français
les actifs j'ai adoré la belle et la
bête
[Musique]
moi celle ci dans des anneaux
sincèrement legolas il m'a traumatisée
quand j'étais petit j'avais pas lu les
livres de tolkien jeu des poulets c'est
un dialogue avec la communauté de
l'anneau
c'est le premier je pète un câble sur
legolas je voulais me laisser pousser
les cheveux et où c'était n'importe quoi
pour le deuxième volet les deux tours je
m'arrange pour le voir dans une salade
et que des fans forcément et là c'était
n'importe quoi il a trop de flou seguin
à moi je peux s'arrête la gare d'assier
l'allemand la lune et il dit un soleil
rouge se lève beaucoup de sang a dû
couler cette nuit levé le côté de moi il
a raison les jours c'est sur le vo c'est
à crier ça sèche et kate tous tes
n'importe quoi moi si wildfire ça n'a
peut-être pas vous parler mais je suis
un fan de nanars wildfire pour moi c'est
le graal des nanars c'est à dire un
nanar ça c'est un film qui est tellement
mal fait qu'il en devient drôle tout
tout tout est nul c'est mon rêve de
partager ça avec une salle entière voilà
je lance un appel
moi je vais en général la nuit j'aime
bien faire deux films à la suite
j'habite sur la ligne 4 lots cinéma aux
halles à moi j'ai cédé donc j'aime bien
terminé et on rentre dans le métro des
lt rentrer chez moi et puis way autre
que j'aime bien la nuit c'est plus calme
j'aime l'expérience du cinéma mais
j'aime pas être collée à tout le monde
je pense
personne d'ailleurs mais pour le coup
est la nuit j'aime bien c'est une place
vide ou simplement une place déjà pas
trop de gens à picoler bien évidemment
je n'aime pas entendre les commentaires
des gens quand je regarde le fil ça me
sort et en même temps j'aime pas non
plus - les déranger avec mes
commentaires mais j'aime bien avoir des
commentaires c'est très hypocrite comme
leur relation au public dans le cinéma
mais du coup moi je vais là où il ya peu
de monde
en bas à droite en bas à gauche s'est
jamais au milieu parce que tout le monde
va milieu franchement ça va j'ai une
bonne vue pas de problème par rapport à
ça j'ai pas de jeu pas de souci j'aime
bien aller au cinéma au moins deux donc
en général on parle du film après non
pas solo pas sous l'eau j'aime pas être
solo à la base
quoi qu'il ait même si je suis souvent
seul par la tristesse du gap 1
si justement salle en fait c'est un
choix un nom je m'isole beaucoup pour
écrire pour travailler mais j'aime bien
le monde même si pendant le film c'est
relou d'être trop parce que quand tu
fais une bonne vanne à quelqu'un à côté
tu dois la foire aux autres aussi mais
j'aime bien après le film j'adore
débattre du film est parfois ses marrons
pas on passe complètement à côté de ce
que l'autre a ressenti passé le mien
sincèrement c'est mon troisième film
rochus contre césar pas parce que j'ai
envie de le voir en salle parce que
c'est mon film paraît godet parce que
d'habitude si on met des premiers films
en tout cas on a fait des projections en
amont et j'ai fait une grosse tournée
d'avant-premières où j'ai pu montrer le
film au public et observer leurs
réactions
moi je vous jure de tarés qui va au
cinéma quand son film est sorti et qui
se cachent dans les escaliers pour
entendre des réactions du public j'ai
besoin de ça je viens de la scène j'ai
besoin de la réaction du public